pour la première fois en quatre mois les
péruviens peuvent se rendre au
restaurant ce lundi les restrictions
liées aux kobe 19 se sont assouplies
dans la ville de lima seule obligation
lavage des mains et port du masque à
l'intérieur de l'établissement des
règles auxquelles les clients semblent
s'habituer
nous sommes en train de réapprendre les
nouvelles manières de manger de se
déplacer de naviguer et jusqu'à présent
c'est confortable bien sûr c'est une
expérience qui le marquera
définitivement pour la vie ils nous ont
guidés depuis le début au marché ou se
laver les mains ou walt et comment se
déplacer afin de ne pas croiser les gens
qui entrent ou sortent les protocoles
sont bons dans la limite des attentes
d'autres restrictions pour les
restaurateurs cette fois ci leurs
établissements ne peuvent accueillir que
40 % de leurs capacités
les tables doivent être séparées d'au
moins deux mètres
ici elles sont installées au deuxième
étage et les commandes à emporter sont
préparés au premier jeu n'est que le
deuxième étage pour accueillir les
clients nous gardons la distance en
veillant à ce que l'étape ça c'est paris
le plus important est de se laver les
mains de ne pas se toucher le visage car
on ne sait pas ce qu'on a touché surtout
ne pas se toucher le visage et ceux qui
paient constamment notre personnel est
toujours équipée
d'après les chiffres de la chambre
nationale du tourisme au pérou soixante
dix mille entreprises ont définitivement
fermé leurs portes suite à l'épidémie
un phénomène qui aurait supprimé des
milliers d'emplois dans le pays selon
l'université johns hopkins le pérou est
le sixième pays du globe le plus touché
par la pandémie de coronavirus avec plus
de 350000 contaminé confirmé